let's bring in white house press
secretary jen saki she's here ahead of
president biden's first u.n general
assembly address as president and uh jen
i want to get to that uh it's a big
address from the president but these
images along the border are shocking and
the bar is high for shocking images
along the border you've called them
horrific
what did the president say how did he
feel when he saw them he also felt they
were horrific and horrible i don't know
anyone who could watch that video and
not have that emotion
last night our secretary of homeland
security put out a statement conveying
there would be an investigation that
he's going to send additional personnel
i think it's important for people to
know this is not who we are that's not
who the biden harris administration is
and we're going to absolutely pursue
that investigation and get to the bottom
of what happened here meanwhile
deportation flights are ongoing and i
think what's confusing for people there
is secretary my orcis back in may said
to haitian nationals already here we
know things are so terrible in your
country that you're going to get a
temporary extension we're not going to
send you back your case is going to be
ongoing you're going to be here
shouldn't that same idea apply now
you're right temporary protected status
which is something the secretary and the
secretary of state also put in place
they actually extended it further
because of the turmoil on the ground
into later in the summer now anyone who
is here before then may be eligible for
temporary protected status
and we're looking into that people may
be eligible for that but right now we
also have to implement our laws at the
border we also want to protect people
both in that community but also migrants
one of the challenges as we're all
facing a pandemic here is the gathering
of so many people we're still implanting
title 42 which means that we are going
to send people out of the country who
come in as we implement that a coveted
safety protocol exactly but did you say
that it's possible that that extension
that applies to haitians already here
could apply to those coming across the
border well tony it's already been
extended uh because of the turmoil on
the ground it was earlier this summer
that's something that the secretary of
homeland security and secretary of state
do look into but again as we look to the
the photos not just the ones you
referenced but but of all of these
families and people under the bridges we
wanted to also take steps to implement
our laws and to protect a lot of them
from the spread of covet as well you
know there's a lot of incoming jen
at the white house these days what will
be the president's message today at the
united general assembly well he he
appears to be really under the gun on so
many different levels well the way the
president views it and we all view it is
that's what you do as president you
navigate crises you weather storms and
we're certainly doing that right now but
this is a huge opportunity today for the
president he's obviously been on the
world stage for a long time but he's
going to say to the world all the
leaders in the room we're not looking
inward after we end a 20-year war we're
going to look outward and we're going to
prioritize what's most important to
address whether that's the climate
crisis whether that's cyber threats
continuing to work with partners on
counter terrorism
and that's what we need to have our
resources and focus and our eyes on and
we're going to do that through
rebuilding our allies and partnerships i
think it's good to say we're going to
look outward but we can't ignore it has
happened before we're still getting
hammered for
how the the withdrawal from afghanistan
happened everybody knows every many
people believe it was time it's just the
way that it was done so we all agree
with that that's not a good look you
look at what's happening with
immigration you look at france now
saying that
they've been betrayed by the united
states so i get that we have to look
forward but what are we doing to
justify or explain what appears to be
very bad behavior on our part now
we don't see it that way one we have a
long abiding relationship friendship
alliance with france what we're talking
about here this is about an economic
deal we have the best nuclear sub
technology in the world and the
australians wanted our technology prior
to that they were buying uh they were
buying uh this from france we understand
that they're they're just pleased about
that but we have a long abiding
friendship with them that's going to
endure and and we are going to rely on
that long history of friendships but i
think the president is the first to say
you've got to work on relationships we
know this in our real lives as well
and he's and he's here to do that too so
when he speaks to the world today he's
going to convey alliances are the
backbone of who we are we're going to
build and address these issues in the
world based on those alliances climate
cyber counterterrorism whatever it may
be now speaking of those relationships
how does he plan to address the
relationship with china that has been
described as dysfunctional
well i we heard the un secretary general
describe it that way we don't agree with
that assessment the president met with
him uh last night and conveyed uh you do
not have to be concerned that we're
trying to start a cold war with china
that is not what the united states is
going to do and the president will
address that in his speech today but we
do see the relationship through the
prism of competition it is a china is a
competitor but it's not a country we
want to have conflict with so what
people will hear the president talk
about is where we have issues we will
raise them but we will also look to
areas where we can work together and we
need to work together and the u.n
secretary general has also said that on
climate change time is up that needs to
unite the world action needs to happen
meanwhile here in this country joe
manchin senator from west virginia made
a half million dollars on coal
production last year
his son runs a coal company that he
founded and he's got more donations from
fossil fuel companies than anyone else
in the senate what's the world supposed
to think when they see that's the
individual helping shape climate policy
here in this country well i think a lot
of people in congress would argue that
he's start he's shaping climate policy
in the united states we do need his vote
in order to get the president's package
across the finish line that is going to
be a historic investment in addressing
the climate crisis president agrees with
the u.n secretary general but what we're
trying to do right now we're navigating
through sausage making is messy so even
as the president's at the u.n general
assembly our team at home is working
with members of congress to get this
package that has a huge climate
investment across the finish line the
world will certainly be watching you're
right and americans should feel
confident in that climate package given
the author of it or a key shaper of that
policy joe manchin well i think
americans can look at the details
american people are smart we don't need
to underestimate their intelligence out
there not suggesting you are not
suggesting you are but anyone who is
should not do that what they can see is
this is a historic investment in
electric vehicles and setting high
standards and making sure that we are
making the investment now to address
what is a crisis that is happening now
we need to just take steps now all right
well it's nothing yet but it's being
worked on we're getting there they will
stay with us
later
that's right very messy always all right
jen thank you very much thank you
appreciate it